لقد رأينا التكنولوجيا التي
شهدناها في لحظات تغيير قواعد اللعبة ، الآن
Var على وشك إطلاقها في الدوري الإنجليزي
الممتاز ، لذا فإن ما يجب أن نتوقعه
في جوهره سيخدم وظيفتين رئيسيتين
لتنبيه أي أخطاء واضحة وواضحة
والإبلاغ عن جدية  الأحداث الفائتة
سينطبق هذا على أربعة سيناريوهات لتغيير اللعبة ،
عقوبات الأهداف
، بطاقات الشارع الحمراء والهوية الخاطئة ، أحد
التحديات هو مراجعة الأحداث
دون تعطيل الوتيرة السريعة
وإنهاء تدفق اللعبة ، سيكون مفتاح هذا هو
الاتصال الوثيق بين on  -
حكم الميدان وحكام مساعدي الفيديو من
أجل تجنب الحاجة إلى مراجعة جانب الملعب لمدة
60 ثانية حتى ينتقل
الحكم إلى RRA لمراجعة الحادث
ثم أكثر من 30 ثانية لإعادة المكان ،
أي 90 ثانية يتم إخراجها تلقائيًا
من اللعبة والتي  نحن نعيد التفكير
لصالح ما يبدو أننا نحافظ عليه فقط من
خلال تقديم المشورة للواقع الافتراضي للقرار على نفس القدر من
الأهمية ، على الرغم من أننا سنبقي المشجعين في حالة
تواجد أثناء عملية المراجعة ، لذلك  الآن
ولأول مرة ستُعرض عمليات الإعادة
على الشاشة الكبيرة والملاعب ، والمشجعون
الذين يذهبون إلى المباريات هم من
المهم جدًا أنهم هم الذين ينفقون
الأموال للذهاب كثيرًا في اللعبة لا
يعني أنهم مهمون.  بقيت على
اطلاع بما يجري في الدوري
الإنجليزي الممتاز كما قامت بتعديل var في المناطق
التي لم تعمل حتى الآن
مثل مراقبة مواقع حراس المرمى
خلال كأس العالم للسيدات في فرنسا
، تعرضت التكنولوجيا لانتقادات
شديدة بسبب معاقبة الحراس لكونهم مجرد  بوصات
من خطهم أثناء ركلات الترجيح
مما أدى إلى عمليات إعادة الفوز والبطاقات الصفراء
الآن ، ولكن لن يتم استخدامها بعد الآن
ما لم تكن هناك حاجة واضحة
للتدخل لجميع الدروس المستفادة
خلال طرح VA ass العالمي على مدار
العامين الماضيين ، من
المحتمل أن يكون الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز  أن يكون أكبر اختبار لها
حتى الآن مع وجود مئات الملايين من
الدولارات على المحك في الصراع على الألقاب
والتأهل الأوروبي ، فإن
اتخاذ القرار الصحيح سيكون الآن أكثر
أهمية من  من أي وقت مضى
ولكن EPL يقول إنهم مستعدون ،
ستحدث الأشياء كما تعلمون ، وهذا
هو الجمال هناك ،
وسأكون بالتأكيد مفتوحًا لقضاء عطلة نهاية أسبوع هادئة
في الأول ولكن إذا لم يحدث
ذلك ، فأنا متأكد من أن حياتنا في  مكان رائع
في وضع جيد لتكون قادرًا على فعل
ما يتم عرضه أمامهم
كريستينا مكفارلاند CNN
[موسيقى]